[Applaudissements]
tout le monde alors je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui d'une d'une belle aventure
une aventure d'abord une aventure
d'abord littéraire puis
cinématographique et enfin sociale alors
l'histoire a commencé en 2003 1 16 mai
2003 quatorze jeunes sont sortis d'un
bidonville sidi moumen et ont fait un
carnage
à casablanca des kamikazes 14 jeunes
âgés entre 18 et 25 ans et alors voilà
donc on s'est réveillé un jour et et ça
a explosé chez nous on n'était pas
habitué on pensait qu'on était immunisé
contre le terrorisme et ben non on s'est
réveillé un matin et et voilà chez nous
aussi ça peut exploser
chez nous aussi ça peut voilà on pensait
que terrorisme c'était loin c'était en
tchétchénie palestine qu'on était loin
parce que le marocain n'est pas
quelqu'un n'est pas quelqu'un de violent
le maroc est sympathique nous n'avons
pas la culture de la violence dans l'eau
gèle les marocains vraiment je le vois
comme quelqu'un de sympa on s'arrête
dans la raab encore dans la rue pour
demander un chemin il ya dix personnes
qui sont là pour pour indiquer le chemin
évidemment il vous donne dix réponses
différentes mais mais mais bon le maroc
n'est pas donc je voulais comprendre un
peu ce qui nous arrivait et on m'a dit
que les jeunes sont tous venus de sidi
moumen je me suis dit je vais faire le
déplacement à sidi moumen et voir un peu
à quoi ressemblait ce bidonville parce
que des bidonvilles
il y en a un peu partout dans ce pays
dans autour des villes et ses agents
voient partout et là j'ai fait le
déplacement à ces dix mots mais c'était
pas facile après après les attentats de
de sidi moumen ce n'était pas facile au
départ de rentrer dans ces dix moments
parce que il y avait beaucoup de
policiers beaucoup de journalistes et
les gens les gens du bidonville était
étaient méfiants mais j'avais un copain
journaliste qui était originaire de sidi
moumen et ce copain m'a fait entrer à
l'intérieur des des baraques à
l'intérieur je voulais voir un peu à
quoi ressemble et 7,7 ce cloaque
incroyable où vivait à l'époque
trois cent mille habitants c'est une
ville c'est un bidonville
c'est une ville où il y a des égouts
éventrés des délais de la tôle ondulée
de ça ressemblait à tout sauf au maroc
d'ailleurs au maroc on connaissait pas
moi personnellement je suis né au fin
fond de la médina de marrakech
je n'ai jamais vu une chose pareille et
d'ailleurs il ya une muraille quand on
passe entre casa et rabat on ne voit pas
ce dimanche le toutou paris jolis seins
c'est à dire le yen n'est pas agressé
par pas set par set cette horreur et
donc je me suis dit la première image
que j'ai eues en entrant à sidi moumen
ça a été des gamins qui jouaient au
football sur une décharge du sud tient
cela ils deviendront les héros de mon
nouveau roman donc j'écris j'ai commencé
par écrire un roman qui s'appelle les
étoiles de sidi moumen
on nage écrit ce roman est évidemment
j'ai commencé à l'écrire
j'ai commencé à l'écrire en 2004 et en
2006 j'ai arrêté la rédaction du texte
parce que je m'en sortais pas je m'en
sortais pas jeu gt gt en train de trop
comprendre que lorsqu'on est dans la
crasse lorsqu'on n'a pas d'horizon
eh ben on a envie de s'exploser on a
envie de 2
on n'a plus envie de vivre on a envie de
de casser la baraque
et ça je ne pouvais pas l'écrire moi je
ne pouvais pas justifier l'injustifiable
je pouvais pas faire l'apologie du
terrorisme donc j'ai arrêté de la
rédaction du texte en 2006 et puis j'ai
pris des vacances j'ai écrit un petit
livre sur marrakech qui s'appelle le
griot de marrakech
c'était des légendes sur la ville et
c'est une commande d'un éditeur espagnol
et et au bout d'un an et demi évidemment
le texte poursuivent et il fallait
absolument que je le finisse et j'ai
trouvé une solution pour finir ce texte
j'ai trouvé une solution pour finir ces
textes c'est à dire j'ai fait aimer ces
gamins aux lecteurs parce que c'est de
très souvent quand on parle de kamikazes
on les voit très souvent comme l'espèce
de monstre dans tout le cinéma américain
dans les cinémas dans la littérature
on nous présente toujours le kamikaze
comme un type monstrueux et mois les les
les gens que j'ai rencontrés sidi moumen
les familles des kamikazes j'étais des
enfants ordinaires et donc je les voyais
pas comme des monstres
évidemment ils ont fait un axe
monstrueux vous ne les voyez pas quand
même ans je ne voyais pas comme des
monstres je le voyais comme comme des
victimes
les véritables monstres dans cette
affaire c'est évidemment l'état qui
laisse trois cent mille personnes vivent
dans la cresse une zone de non droit à
une zone
terrifiant en laissant des gens vivre
dans la crasse évidemment il ya pas que
l'état ya cette mafia religieuse qui
s'est installée dans dans ce cloaque
dans ce dans ces bidonvilles et qui ont
fait un travail pour conditionner les
gamins donc cette matière religieuse qui
n'a rien à voir avec la religion c'est 1
les organisations politiques organisés
riche avec un argent qui vient de d'ici
ou là de certains pays amis
donc cette matière religieuse
ce sont eux sont des monstres les
bourgeois de casa aussi qui paye les
gens 1500 dirhams une bonne ou au
gardien il participe un peu à cette
affaire donc voilà tout le monde est
responsable mais si gamal à ses gammes à
la ils sont pas ils sont pas monstrueux
ce sont des victimes qu'il faudrait
défendre et protéger quand j'ai écrit le
livre le livre a eu un certain succès on
est déjà 15 traduction et il ya un
metteur en scène marocain qui s'appelle
nabil ayouch qui a décidé d'adapter le
le roman au cinéma on s'est mis d'accord
dudu fait quoi nous étions d'accord sur
sur le sur le fait que ces gamins-là
sont des victimes
on a fait affaire il ay l'aï là il a
fait un super film qui s'appelle les
chevaux de dieu et pendant le tournage
pendant le tournage j'avais temps en
temps aux bidonvilles voir un peu
comment ça se passe et je voulais voir
un peu comment ça se passait et il avait
engagé des enfants du de sidi moumen
avait engagé des enfants du bidonville
comme acteur y en avait une dizaine une
dizaine de gamins et pendant pendant
qu'on pendant la pause au moment de la
pause déjeuner je voyais ces gamins
remplir leurs assiettes comme les vins
buffet il avait peur que ça se termine
l'achète
le tournage a duré un mois un mois et
demi et donc ils remplissent et leur
assiette et et y manger ici j'ai regardé
avec nabil j'ai dit ne regarde
il me dit où il faisait ça fait ça fait
six mois que je leur ai pris un
appartement jeu pour les former et ses
abords
la formation pour devenir acteur pour
jouer dans le match ça fait six mois
qu'ils sont là y sont propres ils
mangent bien ils ont grossi gisent
maintenant qu'ils suivent en fait il m'a
dit mais qu'est ce que tu veux que j'en
fasse il y en a 10 + 4 14
qu'est ce que tu veux des gens presse je
suis pas une assistante sociale dit
voilà il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
pour ces gamins et là un soir quand le
film est sorti et qui est le film a très
bien fonctionné on a été à cannes on a
été aux états unis on la présentait un
peu partout dans le monde
des fois quand il pouvait pas y aller
j'y allais à sa place c'est à dire on
est devenus on a fait on sait en effet
le mariage ils ont un mariage de un
mariage de raison
et un soir un soir on s'est dit bon il
faut qu'on on a gagné beaucoup d'argent
avec cette affaire moi j'ai gagné vendu
beaucoup de livres toi tu es tu
beaucoup de gens m'ont vu ton film il
faudrait qu'on le rende quand même et on
a décidé qu'on allait ouvrir un centre
culturel dans le bidonville à sidi
moumen
on a décidé qu'on allait ouvrir un
centre culturel et on n'avait pas un
rond
si on avait gagné de l'argent mais il
fallait beaucoup d'argent pour un centre
culturel et on j'ai sollicité tous les
amis comme je suis peintre j'ai beaucoup
d'amis artistes
donc j'ai sollicité une centaine
d'artistes dans le monde des copains des
copains de copains et on j'ai rassemblé
une centaine d'oeuvres et on a fait une
vente aux enchères à casablanca et on a
ramassé un bon paquet d'argent et puis
on a été voir le maire de sidi moumen
on les dit voilà de noël locales ont
ah on va te faire un centre culturel je
crois qu'on est on va le voir un peu
marre là ça s'est passé pas le centre
culturel c'est trop beau pour être le
centre culturel on on a le le maire nous
a fait confiance nous a donné un local
de 2000 m couverts et dans ce local
on a fait une salle de cinéma théâtre
une salle de musique une salle de danse
une médiathèque avait quinze mille
livres et et voilà l'aventuré partie on
engageait des d une directrice un
assistant des intervenants les artistes
du pays tous les copains viennent donner
des cours on a fait des partenariats
avec les les centres culturels étrangers
français espagnol allemand et donc nous
nous donnons des cours de langues dans
dans cet espace dans le conte appelé
évidemment les étoiles de sidi moumen
comme comme le livre est là aujourd'hui
on a à peu près 500 gamins inscrits et
500 autres qu'on laisse entrer même
s'ils ne sont pas inscrits parce qu'il
faut ils n'ont pas même les 100 dirhams
pour pour s'inscrire
donc on a à peu près on tourne autour de
1000 personnes à sidi moumen et voilà ce
sont des gens qui peuvent qui peuvent
relativement
[Applaudissements]
et puis évidemment une fois que le
centre a été lancé maintenant il est
autonome il ne dépend plus de nous
puisqu'on à trouver des financements
pour pour qu'il continue à vivre mais
sans nous et là on arona des
partenariats on a on arrive à le sens de
sidi moumen arrive à vivre sans nous ce
qui s'est passé un jour il ya un type
qui est venu et qui reste riche une
heure dans le centre
il avait une bonne tête les types et
puis il nous a dit voilà moi je vous
financez deux centres comme celui là
choisissez et je vous donne deux 2 ans
d'autonomie et après vous débrouiller
pour le et donc il nous a donné
il ya des gens comme ça ta existe
c'est-à-dire ya l'humain est encore de
l'humanité dans ce monde il ya des gens
comme ça qui viennent un jour je vais
pas le nommer parce qu'il ne veut pas
que je nomme mais c'est un type juste
formidable voilà il ya dix mois je vous
offre deux sens donc on a ouvert un
centre à fès et un centre à tanger
tanger mini makada il a démarré il ya il
ya quelques jours ou 20 jours un mois à
peu près et là ça y est c'est parti
nous sommes en train d'ouvrir un centre
à marrakech un attentat à ouarzazate et
un à essaouira s'est pas encore fait
donc voilà il ya plusieurs centres qui
sont en train de naître mais maintenant
je canton viennent demander pour ouvrir
un centre dans une ville je demande des
financements à la ville je demande de
financement c'est à dire c'est à dire
combattre le terrorisme c'est pas aller
bombarder de les gens chez eux et faire
des millions de réfugiés en europe qui
viennent mendier qu'on rejette de
portable c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
combattre le terrorisme c'est aller la
wii ou louise née la ruhr où
où il va naître là où il va grandir là
où il va pousser c'est à dire aller dans
des endroits comme sidi moumen et dire
aux gamins voilà on va vous apprendre la
culture de la vie vous allez aimer la
vie parce que les autres là les
part à côté eh ben ils vous montrent une
culture de la mort et et nous les
combattons nous les combattrons nous
sommes en guerre parce que non nous
travaillons dans le même secteur
quand il ya eu le film de nabil ayouch
match love
ils ont fait un sitting devant le centre
pour dire il faut cayouche sorte parce
qu'il aux divers gronde et vos filles
donc voilà nous nous sommes dans une
espèce de combat et et nous sommes nous
sommes en train de de de réussir quelque
chose qui est fantastique puisque le
jour où où il ya eu un sitting de barbus
devant le centre de sidi moumen
ce sont les femmes avec leurs enfants
qui ont forcé le passage et ça a été
notre première victoire
les jeunes ont chassé les islamistes dit
voilà moi mon enfant je veux qu'il aille
à prendre à la musique je veux qu'ils
allaient apprendre les langues c'est à
dire nous pouvons arranger ce pays voilà
ceci est notre petite revanche
ceci notre petite revanche contre
l'inhumain avec des moyens esthétique je
vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]